this is our guide of what to watch read
see follow do and listen to over the
weekend
up first have you missed those three
little words
ready set bake then this weekend you
gotta watch the new season of the great
british bake off
the most soothing show on earth is back
on netflix
so excited to binge 10 full hours of
peace
pastry and paul hollywood
next sometimes i want to stop looking at
my phone
and start living gosh darn it well
there's an app for that
it's called forest app and it grows a
little virtual tree
as long as you don't check your phone
the longer you do screen lists
the bigger it grows and if you grow
enough
virtual trees the app makers plant real
life trees too
so far they've planted over 883
000 of them
i mean that's two reasons to get on this
app
right eric cunningham that's right
moving on if you like poems as much as i
do
then we've got the podcast perfect for
you
it's called the daily poem and it
features everyone from
langston hughes to shakespeare to maya
angelou and each episode has a little
background on the poet
that um whose work you're about to hear
and it's a great way to fit a little
poetry in your day and i'm actually
lately i've i wake up and i look at my
phone i'm not growing a tree i'm looking
at the phone
and i said you know what i want the
first thing i see
to be a poem and i want to start my day
that way so this is an amazing way to do
that or have it at any point
moving on if you're looking for a new
project to tackle
but need some inspiration
well you have to follow darcy miller on
instagram
at darcy miller okay darcy is a friend
of mine and she's an author
a master crafter and illustrator and a
party planning genius
she's an editor at martha stewart for
the past 25 years
she is a fountain of inspiration for
arts and crafts
home design great after school projects
you can do with your kids
virtual party planning and so much more
in fact she's gonna come on the show in
a couple weeks to help us get ready
for halloween but the thing that i love
about darcy
is being in her world is just a really
wonderful place
she really creates like a parallel
universe that's just
so sweet and delightful and i'm telling
you
you can get really lost in it so i'm
excited for that check her out
okay and speaking of halloween it's
pumpkin carving season
one of my favorite fall activities and
i'm not gonna lie i've already carved
like 50 pumpkins with olive and frankie
but the one thing i didn't know about
pumpkin carving
is that you need a pumpkin
carving tool kit because i don't want to
give my children big knives
you know i don't feel like a smart
parent when i do that
so you can get a pumpkin carving kit for
under three bucks in some places
and it has a full set of carvers
scrapers and a mini saw
and it really takes your pumpkin to the
next level safely
well we put the pumpkin carver in a new
section on our website
this i am so excited for drew's little
yellow book
i am so excited about this i
i i it's finally here and you can find
all of my favorite product picks of the
week
and it's a guide just for you made from
me
and my heart and the things i love to
share so
i hope you enjoy that it starts this
weekend drew's
little yellow book you can find it on
our website and that
is the weekender i hope it's a good one